В дитинстві я читав твір «Собака Баскервілів».
І прочитав, як Шерлок Холмз,
побачивши шрифт записки,
визначив у якій газеті його було надруковано.
І я тоді звернув увагу на те, що газети,
які ми отримуємо додому,
набрані різними шрифтами.
Я почав звертати увагу на шрифти.
Тоді все й почалося.
Це культурний код, який,
скоріше за все, підсвідомо зчитується.
Тобто, простіше кажучи,
різницю між готичним надписом і напівуставом,
кожен із нас побачить завдяки тому культурному багажу,
який зорова пам'ять запам'ятовувала ціле життя.
Те, що ти цього не осмислюєш,
не вербалізуєш чи не усвідомлюєш,
зовсім не означає, що воно на тебе не впливає.
Оскільки ми багато читаємо
і більшість інформації отримуємо з читання,
а не через спілкування,
тому наш досвід як читачів є дуже великим.
У кожного він великий.
Можливо, у тих, хто мало читає не так.
Мабуть, це мій перший успішний шрифт.
Він так голосно прозвучав
завдяки своїм виразним зарубкам.
Основна цінність, яку він має — це комунікація.
Польською, українською та грецькою мовами.
Якщо все відбувається добре,
то захоплює сам процес.
Шрифт відіграє роль конструктора
і ти ніколи не знаєш, яким він буде в кінці.
Тобто ти робиш інструмент,
яким будуть працювати інші люди.
У процесі роботи ти набираєш
якесь слово і воно тебе дивує.
Це не так, як з логотипами.
Коли ти одразу бачиш слово і знаєш чого хочеш досягнути.
Малюєш декілька літер,
набираєш їх в рядочок і це виходить цікаво.
Це дуже гарний момент, коли воно разом
створює нові і несподівані для тебе комбінації.
А потім здається, що технічна робота вже готова
і лишається підправити лише відстані
між літерами, то буває нудно.
Далі ти бачиш якесь слово і думаєш,
що в тебе дуже гарний шрифт виходить.
Бігати — це чудово!
Біг — це, по-перше —  ендорфіни,
а, по-друге — ендоканабіноїди.
Тобто, коли ти бігаєш, то у тебе покращується настрій.
Всі бігові наркомани намагаються
придумати ще інші причини, чому вони бігають.
Бо насправді вони всі бігають заради задоволення.
Для шрифтового дизайнера,
який мусить сидіти перед монітором тривалий час,
біг — це прекрасна нагода тривалий час
не сидіти перед монітором.
І займатися якимсь рухом для свого тіла.
Зараз мені більше хочеться робити
дійсно потрібні проєкти як міські шрифти.
Коли є певне завдання, яке шрифт вирішує.
Гляньте, тут з міських шрифтів Дніпро та Маріуполь.
Це був логотип і стиль для Маріуполя,
в рамках якого я робив шрифт для нього.
Цей шрифт є для кирилиці, латинки
та грецької абетки.
Ми зробили так, щоб перетиналися
певною мірою між собою писемності.
Тобто, можна вибрати «р»,
яка схожа на грецьку «ρ».
Можна ось так трошки змішувати.
Для візуальної культури головне,
щоб саме місто було гарним.
А якщо заставити усе місто МАФ-ами,
то, мені здається,
які б букви на них не чіпляй, ефекту
у вихованні чогось цілісного  майже не буде.
Перш за все, треба думати глобально,
щоб людині жилося комфортно у самому місті.
Загалом, трохи сумні справи у цьому плані.
Зараз активувалася команда,
яка відповідає за архітектуру міста.
Можливо, вони навіть приймуть
якийсь дизайн-код.
Ніяк не вдається знайти цю робочу групу,
яка має цим займатися.
Заклеєні вікна на історичних будівлях,
якісь рекламні конструкції,
що мають непропорційні розміри.
Цього всього, звісно, потрібно позбуватися.
Я б взагалі позбувся б рекламних конструкцій у місті.
Тому, що це візуальне сміття.
Це, мабуть, є наступним кроком.
Надпис на готелі «Бердянськ» —
приклад оригінального бердянського шрифту.
Він такий наївний та смішний, але свій.
Це типові 70-ті роки,
але з певним бердянським присмаком.
Людина, яка його робила, була закохана у свою справу.
Я не є справжнім каліграфом.
Для шрифтовика каліграфія
потрібна як джерело натхнення.
Як помічний інструмент у розумінні форм літер.
Як експресивна річ, що якось дозволяє
знайти якусь форму, погратися трохи з цим.
Це швидше схоже на розвагу,
тренування чи руханку.
Я думаю, ви не зможете прочитати те, що я зараз нашкрябав.
Я отримую задоволення від процесу.
Це те, що працюю з матеріалом та
те, що це не залишиться надовго.
Повернеться вітер і водичка все це змиє.
Не треба журитися, що ти зіпсував
своєю писаниною прекрасний берег.
Наскільки він прекрасний.
Я з україномовної родини.
В Бердянську є україномовні родини.
Коли я ріс, то у нас не було українських шкіл.
Взагалі ніяких у місті.
Але мені подобалася українська
і я поступово перестав спілкуватися російською мовою.
Зараз ми бачимо, що люди все простіше і простіше
починають комунікувати українською мовою.
Мені здається, що позитивний процес є очевидним.
Море є тим, на що приємно завжди дивитись.
Море як небо.
У нього ще й можна зануритись.
Я б хотів навчитися плавати на яхті,
але зараз у нас море закрите.
Особливо нікуди на яхті і не попливеш.
Ми стали тією перешкодою,
яка не дозволила побудувати коридор у Крим.
У 2014 році у Мелітополі вже ходили з російським прапором,
Маріуполь було уже захоплено.
А до нас приїхали хлопці і
разом із самообороною заснували те,
що потім стало батальйоном чи полком «Азов».
Чорні чоловічки поїхали ж тоді на Маріуполь.
Тобто, через нас це все й розламалось.
Тому, що воно вже ішло з двох боків.
Хочеться, щоб продовжувало ламатися далі.
Тут теж нова деталь з'явилась,
але в таку погоду я не бачу, мабуть, не видно взагалі.
Приблизно між портом і хвилеламом видно щогли вітряків.
Це дивовижно.
Я й не думав, що можна бачити
якісь конструкції на відстані 30 кілометрів.
Це таке нагадування, що життя міняється,
якісь процеси тривають і з'являється щось нове.
Україна.
Місце, в якому хочеться, щоб було гарно і добре.
За яке переживаєш.
За оцю частину Землі.
У багато чому у нас все гаразд.
Якщо брати до уваги візуальні мистецтва,
то у нас великі успіхи у цій сфері.
Ну як великі. Ми не робимо ще революцію,
але рухаємося у правильному напрямку.
З'явилися школи та ВНЗ, де викладається каліграфія.
Також існують студії.
Все більше народу цим займається.
Це гарно.
У нас історія багата.
Спадок у цьому культурному прошарку
дуже помітний та виразний.
Зараз розширюється коло людей,
які залучені в те, щоб на цьому ґрунті робити щось своє.
Я думаю, що нас попереду чекає цікавий час.